salut tout le monde
je vous prépare un album de fou
mais pour de vrai
bon je sais que
c'est pas très enfin à l'endroit que je
suis dans mon jardin
on entend mon chat
et je vous prépare un album de fou pour
de vrai
la légende black soon 2023 merci
Angèle l'artiste féminine de l'année où
Vitra de la musique bravo
[Musique]
les victoires ah ouais c'est vrai si
jamais arrivé
mais c'est trop bien tant mieux
franchement trop contente ça fait quoi
bah ça fait que
moi et que c'est bizarre je
suis pas très bien quoi dire de plus ça
fait trop plaisir j'étais hyper touché
ce soir et
qui fait ça c'est du véritable cuir
véritable de rien du tout de en
polyester ça c'est un peu de plastique
ici et c'est Vladimir sur son site.com
vous allez pouvoir trouver toutes les
références ça c'est un t-shirt H&M ça
c'est un collier mytho en or mais
évidemment c'est du plaqué ça coûte 4
euros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une belle journée qui commence avec
Mélanie les derniers